this mundane house mouse may hold clues
to when and how humans first started
farming the question is the people first
settled down you know become sedentary
and then later start farming or was
farming the catalyst and made people
stay in one place
so was it hunter-gatherer sedentism and
then farming or hunter-gatherer farming
and then sedentism to figure this out
researchers looked at the distribution
of fossilized mouse teeth from wild mice
and house mice they wanted to know when
house mice began dominating their wild
cousins suggesting the house mice were
living close to humans who had been
there for a while enjoying their
shelters and leftovers according to
their results the house Mouse formed a
beneficial relationship with people
fifteen thousand years ago
this was before farming so that means
people were hunting and gathering in one
place long enough for house mice to form
a relationship with them and out-compete
their wild cousins in the same location
so in this case it looks like it was
hunter-gatherer sedentism farming not
hunter-gatherer farming then sedentism
as a side note it's possible that this
is why you don't see hunter-gatherers
domesticated cats until after they
transition to farming before there was
green for them to poach a mice weren't
considered pests
so no need to keep kitties around to
control them so looking at Mouse teeth
in different locations may give us new
insights into how this transition to
farming happened around the world
[Music]